- Like was it named after popcorn?
Or was it named Popcorn because
popcorn was invented there?
So apparently if I score the lowest,
I have to drink a giant
concoction of all of the answers.
The stakes are high on this one.
I'm not feeling great.
- Popcorn, Indiana.
That has to be fake, right?
That has to be fake.
- The way you said it makes me think
you were just making it up off the spot.
- That's not a real place.
- I would love for that
to be a real place,
but I feel like I would know
I would have heard of this.
I'm gonna say fake.
- Ah!
Bless the citizens of Popcorn, Indiana.
- Oh, Soup, Alabama!
What?
- I don't know how Alabama
would be associated with soup.
- I wanna say Soup, Alabama is true.
It does exist.
- I'm gonna play it safe this time.
I'm gonna say that one is not real.
Soup, Alabama.
No, it's not real.
- Oh, I'm doing so well!
- Good, 'cause Soup,
Alabama just sounds silly.
Sounds like a really bad porn name.
- Kind of like rolls off
your tongue which is nice.
- That can't be real.
This is crazy.
Who's from Hot Coffee, Mississippi?
Please like find me and
tell me who you are.
- Chili, Wisconsin.
I'm from Wisconsin.
I don't remember a city named Chili.
- Is there a Wisconsin chili?
- Chili, Wisconsin is a real place.
No, no, no, no.
- I'm so good at this!
- That doesn't sound that crazy.
- Oh, man.
Okay, if this isn't real...
- No, that's not real.
I think there is another city like that,
but I don't think Apple,
Pennsylvania is real.
- Son of a bitch!
- Doesn't that just sound
like the name of the town
in every Hallmark movie?
- Oh, no!
I can't drink anything with mayo.
- You know, I don't want
it to be a real place
because it's so obvious.
- I would be more suspicious of
Mayonnaise, Florida, let's say,
but Mayo, Florida I bet could exist.
- Of course Florida's got a Mayo.
- Toast, North Carolina.
Oh, shoot.
- I'm just gonna go with my gut.
It's real.
- Yeah, this is real 'cause
I know this is a real city.
I know Toast.
- Who named all of these towns?
Like, "This land shall be named Toast!"
Okay.
- [Man] That should be good.
Don't forget this.
Eww.
- This is...